[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
my
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
huh
[Music]
um
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
uh
[Music]
come here
[Music]
me
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening welcome to this special
concert in honor of puerto rico
and uh you just heard the fantastic
amazing
son of puerto rico miguel xenon
in an array of soloist ini oguntola on
the clarinet
tony terraza on the alto saxophone
larry wang and peter godard on piano
dylan sleeper on tenor saxophone
alan osbinson on the trumpet
and chase vogeli on the drums
this is an original composition by
miguel
entitled ceremonial
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
movies
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
ah
[Music]
my
teddy
[Music]
my
[Music]
me
[Music]
hey
my
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
alan osmondson on the flugal horn
miguel zenon composer saxophonist
[Applause]
part of this journey that we're on as
you may know
this ensemble along with miguel xenon
and my amazing colleague
evan zapporan who i will properly
introduce right now evan zuporin
bass clarinet other clarinets
we were all slated to go to
puerto rico this this past january and
uh that wasn't possible but we are going
january of 19. we're going to be there
and part of this journey was
was education for me not only about the
plight of the island
past and present but also getting to
know what's been going on in our mit
community in terms of
relief and support for puerto rico so
it's been a great pleasure to get to
know
the students of the mit association of
puerto rican students here at mit
so i want to introduce you to the
president and the vice president
this is gabrielle gennario and nina
fred friticelli uh guzman
please welcome them
hello everyone i hope you're feeling
nice and dry and warm in here
you know it's a really cold night but
it's never a bad night to hear some good
music
hi i'm nina fradycherry and i am vice
president of the association of puerto
rican students
and i'm gabriel ginori i'm president of
the mit association of puerto rican
students
and we first want to thank all the mit
festival jazz ensemble as well as miguel
cenan
for coming together and making this
concert
we want to thank you all for sharing
your music with us as well as for
choosing to have your music be a means
of bringing support to the island as
wares
as well as raising awareness to its
current state
last semester once hurricane maria hit
home
apr was hard at work to do our best to
raise awareness and funds to help our
island
and we began by joining forces with
different universities across the nation
and started a gofundme campaign that
ended up raising
around 250 000 that money was donated to
united for puerto rico
an organization that helped bring aid at
critical moments
as well as donated money to nonprofits
on the island
we then proceeded to work on campus and
started a donation drive
that lasted three days and during those
three days we were able to see
mit the mit community's generosity and
support
for us we ended up raising around six
thousand dollars
that we donated to a non-profit on the
island
and raised around four to six pallets
worth of goods ranging from
animal products to food
canned food and hygiene and personal
products
and after the initial aid phase
we now or some of our students actually
went back to puerto rico in
uh in january to work on
uh houses in the rural part of puerto
rico to rebuild
the the roofs um there's another
group of puerto rican students that went
to do field work and research what the
lay of the land was after the hurricane
to come back and report to the mit
community to figure out what we could do
later on there were students who worked
in the government
to try to create uh better digital
systems for the governor of puerto rico
to be faster to respond after
natural disasters and ongoing there are
various things that the mit community
non-puerto ricans
that are part of our community are doing
spring workshops and classes
and thinking about research projects in
the island
and to that we created this or we helped
create a conference called
the communi mit conference on the
brazilian reconstruction of the
caribbean that happened last december
and we were lucky to bring the governor
to actually speak to us and to talk
about what the issues are on the island
regarding electricity housing
infrastructure and water supply and
people from all around the world and
people from the mit community came
together to propose solutions
and hopefully those will carry on
forward with a formal
mit puerto rico and the caribbean
collaboration
that's still in the works and we hope to
be able to announce
uh more developments to come the
moral of the story here is that you know
puerto rico may be small and in the
middle of the ocean but we're here
to uh support it as best we can with our
talent
and into the future of puerto rico i say
you know bring it on
and again we want to thank the ensemble
as well as
and we want to thank you the audience
for supporting and with that we want to
welcome to stage the gentleman that
helped
made it possible for us to take all our
goods to the island and for it to reach
the people that
needed it at the most critical moments
please help us in welcoming pastor henry
monroy
hello everyone my name is henry monroy
a pastor at his sub christian church in
dorchester
from the beginning of this whole mission
i was actually trying to connect myself
with
larger organization some of you guys
might know who he is kurt schilling
because he was promoting
uh that he was going to help puerto rico
and
we started connecting with him um but
something happened between
the process of sending things to puerto
rico
nobody was sending nothing because there
was a miscommunication or something was
happening within the island
that nothing was moving so we started
raising
first aid from everyone in our church
i was assuming that i was going to raise
probably two pallets and
probably raise a thousand dollars and
ship it to puerto rico
uh within the 24 hours our church was
half full of boxes of first aid items
diapers and and anything that everyone
needed
at the time um that's when i started
realizing that
it was a little bit more serious and the
boston blow reached out to me
uh once that happened i just knew that
this was gonna go big
um little by little people started
continuing to come
to our church and we had
different schools and organizations
reaching out to us
and within four to five days
uh we we had we had to start canceling
our services
uh because there were so many uh cases
of water
uh first eight items in our facility
that uh we couldn't have no more service
that's when we connected with mit and
it happened through facebook and then we
came and we we met
the group of students that were out
outside
collecting all the items and we just
connected and i tell them hey
you know whatever it is that you guys
need i'm here to help out
and um let's just connect and make this
happen
uh so shortly after that um
yeah that's the team right there uh we
came we pulled up to our truck and we
just started filling our
you know all the stuff our church is
very small and uh
one of our friends uh he came to the
church and said hey you got to be
careful the structure of the building
might not hold
all the stuff that you have yeah
that's when i called the boston police
and i asked them if they could let us
borrow their parking lot
because we had over 20 pallets of water
people calling from new hampshire maine
all over massachusetts
and i just thought this was going to be
two pallets
surely once i started connecting with
people
u-hauls were pulling in front of the
church um
just unloading all the stuff that they
had and we just said
the doors of the church is open you know
bring it on um
and surely it was it was a lot of stuff
that we had
but right here we had um boston mother's
care
umass lowell blue cross blue shield
and all this thing had all this happened
within hours
of just telling people to help us
and just people showed up it wasn't just
a puerto rico thing it wasn't just
puerto ricans that were coming out
everyone was coming out everyone united
everyone was helping us financially
everyone was helping them with donations
and this is how things get done when
people unite
as one for the same cause and it's to
help humanity out
you know sometimes we need help from
someone else that's why it's important
to connect with other people
this is one of the gentlemen we're
filling up the truck uh on saturday
october
7th i get a phone call at three in the
morning
so i was a little bit concerned because
there's nothing moving uh
they're not accepting nothing in the
island and the boats
all the shipping companies are on hold
at three in the morning
i get a phone call from a gentleman
called
roger cruz he's cuban um and he tells me
uh henry i'm sorry that i'm calling you
at three in the morning
but i have an opportunity to open up and
it's a
overnight shipping uh a flight
and i said how how is this going to
happen and he said we have to drive
from boston to orlando florida right now
i said how are we going to do that i
have like over 20 pallets of water
i have like 20 pallets of diapers 20
pallets of formula
you know 20 pallets of food and he said
i'm going to rent a u-haul in the
morning and whatever fits in that u-haul
we're taking it to orlando and i said
all right
let's cancel our sunday service and sure
enough
people started coming out within half an
hour of uh
of uh you know letting people know hey
we need help and half an hour we had a
group
a large group of people just helping us
out uh
and within the next 24 hours roger cruz
and his girlfriend
mary gloria they drove to orlando
florida
and made it to fedex the faa opened up a
door of 50 tons
a [ __ ] a flight that would take 24 hours
basically to get to puerto rico
so the next day i'm getting the ticket
to go to puerto rico
and i didn't know that i was going to go
to puerto rico that next following day
once i get to puerto rico that's me in
carolina puerto rico
uh with all our stuff within 24 hours
and the best thing about this was that
it was completely free
we didn't pay a dollar and at the end of
the whole thing we sent 27 pallets
without paying a dime
and thanks to the faa that allowed that
allowed us to uh send all these things
over
this is a part of the group that went to
the south side of puerto rico
they took 12 pallets of first eight
items to help them out
uh this is pallets of baby formula
and diapers and stuff like that that we
uh
that we had sent down there to puerto
rico
so this is the bank oriental that's in
san juan puerto rico
i connected with a gentleman called raul
santos
and within three days we asked oriental
the bank to give us a space and they
said take the whole first floor
and just put all the stuff there and get
organized so that's exactly what we did
we just started getting organized
and preparing packages for family
we had over 300 packages of family to
help them
for the next four or five days this is
the group that
raleigh santo connected us with in
puerto rico
the company that they were working for
told them that they can work
uh six uh four hours of community
service and four hours of
just regular work so we just took
advantage of the time
and uh we just started unloading and
packing up all this stuff
and uh this is us getting prepared to go
to the western side of puerto rico
a good team and before we left we prayed
and uh asked god for uh for guidance
for this mission once we arrived to the
western side of puerto rico
so i just want to pause mind you
i didn't plan none of this i'm just in
it for the ride
so uh everything it was it was like a
puzzle
and everything felt like it went
everything just fell into play
and it was just amazing these two
gentlemen are veterans
they came from texas they're not getting
paid for this they're doing this
absolutely volunteer
and they're just protecting us from
anyone that tried to uh
you know step out of their line i would
say
in the western side of puerto rico there
was no water like legitimately
there's no water at all and we found
this
we found this lady with her newborn baby
the baby was born exactly the same day
the storm hit and she had no formula
and there was no water without water
you can't mix up the formula so we made
sure that she had
enough food and items for the baby for
the next week
this gentleman we found him in my west
puerto rico
before the storm he had he he he had
diabetes
and his legs were uh amputated and
he rode the storm basically in his house
the water was six feet high
and um his son was scraping mud off the
walls
while he was attending him uh with
veterans from the
from texas that also joined us with uh
that also joined us to help them out
this gentleman we also met him in maya
west
and he was cleaning out his car uh
because
all the river came out and um
he was trying to clean out his car to
make sure that it worked but there's no
he wouldn't be able to move his car due
to the flood
uh lately that we helped that as well
with formula and
water for the babies i guess that was
number one thing for us
to make sure that these babies were
drinking clean water
and food
in the south side of puerto rico our
group
met with this lady
she started crying because nobody
has helped her out since the storm hit
and um
this was one of the pictures that motiv
you know pushed me
and uh made me realize that we was doing
a great job
she was crying because she hasn't drank
water in over 14 days
and we
we we attended her we helped the whole
community from the south side
and at the end of the day she hugged
everyone from the team and was very
happy and excited
that we went there
so while this is all happening i just
want to
inform that in seong huang uh
most of the people in san juan were they
were pr they were all right in a sense
that
there was some what water but it was
very limited
and we had to drive uh two hours
uh and 45 minutes to help those people
that didn't have
that that help uh this is the military
people
uh from texas that was helping us out um
great guys uh they helped us out
very very nice uh the sign says puerto
rico sing
so basically what it said is puerto rico
arrives without light
without water or without communication
that was a very powerful statement
because at the time
there wasn't a base where the military
the united states military was
taking out water and purifying the water
just for people to be able to take a
shower
and wash their clothes and
and dishes and stuff like that so this
was a military this is a military uh
spot as well this was in the this was in
the
what you see right here in the side
where the two military guys are
are are freezers uh
the death toll of puerto rico there was
over a thousand people that died
in puerto rico so the the building
itself couldn't hold
all the bodies uh when size of the
military had to come out
and place uh
freezers outside uh for the bodies
so all these images uh that i try to
present here is just to show
uh that it wasn't just something that
just came and
just knocked out water and light people
actually heard their lives were really
affected
and a lot of people uh lost their lives
in this
tragic event
so as i'm so i went to puerto rico
a one-way trip and when our mission
finished i said let me go back to boston
i called jetblue and they told me
there's no more flights
so i started reaching out to every other
airline and they're telling me there's
no more flights to november
so now i'm stuck in puerto rico
i'm stuck in puerto rico now and i have
nothing to do because we just finished
giving everything out
and i get a phone call from someone on
facebook
saying that there's a doctor that's
coming from california
at the time when the storm happened
there was a wild fire that was happening
in california
and um dr lamarres and
leslie reached out to us and they said
we have two plane tickets to go to
puerto rico
we need your help i don't know who they
are i said sure
come on and
they came uh loaded with medication
um things to help people out on their
diabetes high blood pressure
uh all this medication they came with
and we just started helping people out
we started going to supermarkets in san
juan and just getting
gallons of water to take it to the
western side of puerto rico
to help more people out and that's us
just going
door by door reaching out to those that
can't
move they can't go to the hospital or
the clinics
within the island that's me and
luisa puerto rigo with the kids
there's a lady in louisa puerto rica as
well she lost her whole house
and yet she's still living within the
house there's no electricity there's no
water
and her structure is clearly of the
house was not livable
uh this picture uh it was very
impacting to me because all you see is
devastation all over
but then you see a little you see a
little kid
swinging or in a playground
that's that for me right there
represents puerto rico
in the midst of a disaster how can you
still focus and have fun
um and that's what this little boy was
doing and that's why i had to snap this
picture
because it was so impacting that i had
to make sure that i taken an
image these are some of the doctors as
well that basically helped us out to
reach the certain
pueblos and make sure that everybody was
attended
with medication and so forth
that's a group that's went also to the
western side of puerto rico with
food and items to help out others
and that's another group that we met in
puerto rico
and we went to the south side of puerto
rico on this occasion to help out a
school
that their whole structure was gone
in this
so we went to puerto rico in september
uh in october i apologize we came back
in december and we left in november
i apologize and then went back in
december again about puerto rico we
ended up sending to puerto rico three
containers
filled with first eight items and it
helped out a lot of people
a few thousand people were helped it
through the help of
everyone here in boston everyone in the
state of massachusetts
and all this could not be done if we did
not unite
and i'm thankful for you guys and i'm
thank you for this opportunity you guys
have given me
um if this was to happen i told this to
the to the professor
i feel like i'm in debt with a lot of
people
because everybody helped my people out
when they needed it
so thank you so much guys for this
opportunity um
and i appreciate all you guys thank you
thank you henry for all you've done and
all you continue to do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my
[Music]
up
[Music]
me
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
la maga composition by miguel xenon
allen osmond on the fluted horn
evan ziporum the bass clarinet evans
deform
dylan sleeper bass flute bass flute
and miguel zenon we're going to do the
next two pieces as a little set
caravan and then after that you will
hear that surprise this is an
arrangement by
peter godard on juan diesel's caravan
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
me
hey
[Music]
food
[Music]
hey
[Music]
uh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
me
[Music]
um
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey
[Music]
uh
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
um
[Music]
me
[Music]
my
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
miguel zanon evan ziporin
before that caravan peter godard tony
terraza
ini oguntola
it's been such an honor to present this
concert um i just have a few people to
thank
uh before we go into the next last two
pieces
um first and foremost the students of
the mit festival jazz ensemble thank you
so so much
i've known heard miguel play live for
the last
13 years i guess now and uh since
2013 we've been collaborating regularly
and it's been one of the greatest joys
of my life this is
an amazing musician in person and uh
we're so thankful to have him here
the mit events office cuco daglio on
sound
tony de bartolo back there recording
the people of puerto rico my goodness
you have inspired me
and i we will continue to inspire me
thank you very much
for this next piece by miguel oh oh
yellow
we're going to bring three special
guests all uh close
close friends and collaborators of
miguel's please welcome to the stage
david rivera miguel martinez and jorge
arsey
well they're getting said i just want to
i don't know if i did enough but i want
to acknowledge again evan
uh who is the chair of our department
evan zapporan and also the head of
cass the center of arts and science and
technology and a world-class player
and to have this the person as a
colleague year after year
i think we collaborate constantly
because we can not not do that
so it's been fantastic so thank you evan
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
be
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
ben harped on tenor dylan sleeper on
tenor saxophone
kevin costello with a trombone
three percussionists gavin miguel
jorge
thank you so much everyone thank you
fred and the band it's really
just a privilege always to collaborate
with fred and everyone here at mit
and this amazing group of musicians
they've been working hard on this music
uh for the past couple months and it's
just really inspiring to be here and get
to uh
finally have it played and then have you
all here to share this this
moment with us is really meaningful so
thank you so much for being here and
supporting the cause
um i i really have to um acknowledge uh
fred's
uh work through all of this he's really
been the uh the brains behind this whole
operation
he reached out to me i want to say maybe
a couple years ago
about bringing this band down to the
island
and and doing uh various activities
there from concerts to
educational activities cultural
exchanges etc and we've been planning
this trip for a while
uh obviously it had to be postponed for
obvious reasons but
fred was the one that was really pushing
hard about having this concert tonight
we're going to have the same concert in
new york tomorrow
really more than anything else we're
just trying to create awareness
about the situation that's still going
on in puerto rico i mean you saw that
footage
from earlier it was very very powerful
footage you know
but it's really sad to say that that's
still going on in certain parts of
puerto rico there's there's folks
without water
without electricity without very very
very very very basic
everyday needs and they really need all
the help they get
uh you know there's a lot of stuff going
on in the world a lot of stuff going on
in this country in our country in puerto
rico also
so it's easy you know for this to be all
news
because it happened five months ago six
months ago but
you should know that is that is still
still going on there's still a lot of
need there
there's still a lot of a lot of chaos
unfortunately going on in the island
so we're just trying to really create
awareness
for folks like yourselves and everyone
out there who's listening
that uh you know any anything you can do
to help uh
is is greatly needed and greatly i'm
sure is greatly appreciated
by the folks down there this last piece
we're going to play is a piece i wrote
specifically for tonight it's the first
time we've ever played it in public
we've been rehearsing it for the last
couple days and uh
i wrote this piece thinking about
various things you know one of the
one of the main things that's happened
it was also already happening before the
the disaster but
especially after the hurricanes hit a
lot of puerto ricans
started leaving the island for obvious
reasons some of them
you know didn't have a home they needed
medical help
um you know they needed a job
so they started migrating to the united
states and elsewhere
but a lot of people did stay you know on
the island and they
kind of you know they kind of grinded
through it
and they're still grinding through it i
have a lot of friends from artists
to uh you know most small business
owners who
decided to stay there and do what they
could to
build that country back up uh so i wrote
this piece for them
thinking about them and thinking about
the resiliency and the courage
a lot of these people in puerto rico a
lot of the people are trying to help out
the situation there
and this one is called empia de lucha
it's going to close out the concert so
thank you very much thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
let's
me
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
people go to puerto rico
puerto rico mit festival
you